ABCs of AI B is for Bert bird stands for
bi-directional encoder representations
from Transformers it's a neural network
based language model that was introduced
by Google AI researchers in 2018. Bert
is trained on a massive data set of text
and code and can be used to perform a
variety of natural language processing
tasks like question answering sentiment
analysis named entity recognition and
more the beat and Bert stands for
bi-directional which means it can
process text in both directions which
allows it to understand the context of
words in a sentence take the sentence
the Tomato that was on the plant is red
Bert knows that the Tomato was red even
though the adjective is at the end of
the sentence this is also one of the
reasons why Google search is so good at
understanding your weirdly formed search
request
check out some more cool stuff related
to Bert in the description what other AI
topics do you want to know more about on
the next episode of